We can see on TV and in the news.
Watson, Who is Michael Phelps. Yes.
That artificial intelligence is no longer found only in the
movies.
I'm sorry Dave.
I'm afraid I can't do that.
It's beginning to enter everyday life. But can a computer make decisions requiring moral judgment?
(scream)
As AI blurs the boundary between human and machine, can technology handle the complex world we live in?
Look, I need help. I need to know more about morality.
I don't know what ethics is.
Some powerful voices are starting to question what we're creating.
I think we should be very careful about artificial intelligence.
If I were to guess...at what
our biggest existential threat is, it's probably that.
In 2015 an open letter urging caution
in the development of artificial intelligence
in weapons systems was signed by more than 150 experts
including Elon Musk and Stephen Hawking.
The development of artificial intelligence could spell the end of the human race.
Once humans develop artificial intelligence that would take off on it's own,
and redesign itself at an ever increasing rate.
Humans who are limited by a slow biological evolution couldn't compete, and would be superseded.
Will our machines turn against us?
With artificial intelligence we are summoning the demon.
But can morality be programmed?
Siri what is the meaning of life?
I don't believe there is a consensus on that question.
Life, a principle or force that is considered
to underlie a distinctive quality of animate beings.
I guess that includes me.
Yeah good luck.
Siri what is the meaning of life?
I don't believe there is a consensus on that question.
It's nothing Nietzsche couldn't teach ya.
Very funny.
One more. Siri what is the meaning of life?
I don't believe there is a consensus on that question.
Well it's hard to imagine our life without computers.
And sometimes we wish we were...
I'm sorry.
Sorry, she's not completely human yet I guess.
It's hard to imagine life without these things that have sneaked into our life
like siri and MS's Cortana I believe. I'm a Mac person so I don't know about Cortana.
Computer technology has so quickly become seamlessly interwoven into everyday life.
But have we had the chance to really think about the consequences? Do we even know how?
What kind of ethical guidelines do we need for the development and use of this technology?
Who's responsible when a driverless car gets into an accident which seems inevitable.
Autonomous weapons systems
are being developed by the U.S., the U.K.,
England, Russia...autonomous weapons and China.
And I've just learned at least a few dozen
other countries that are already developing
autonomous weapons systems that make their own decisions.
Should a machine be given the
autonomy to make life and death decisions?
Can morality be coded? How close are we to that
wonderful sympathetic character Commander
Data that was created in the mind of
Gene Roddenberry for Star Trek The Next Generation
30 years ago.
So to understand these questions or get a
way of thinking about them.
Our first guest is a scientist, a best selling
author, entrepreneur and professor of psychology at NYU.
He's also the CEO and co-founder of
the recently formed Geometric Intelligence.
His research on language computation, artificial intelligence
and cognitive development has
been published in leading journals such as
Science and Nature and several others.
He's a frequent contributor to The New Yorker and
The New York Times. Please welcome Gary Marcus.
Next up is a senior researcher at Microsoft.
Prior to joining Microsoft he was a senior
scientist at Yahoo research. His primary research
interest is data mining, web search and evaluation
of machine learning.
His work in the ethics of online systems has been presented at several conferences.
He's the organizer of a 2016 workshop on ethics
of online experimentation.
Please welcome Fernando Diaz.
And next we have the director of the human robot interaction laboratory at Tufts University.
He's also a program manager of the new Center
for Applied brain and cognitive sciences joint
program with the U.S. Army.
In addition to studying robot behavior he
works in the field of artificial life,
artificial intelligence, cognitive science and philosophy.
Please welcome Mathias Schuetz.
Our next guest is a consultant
ethicist and scholar at Yale University's Interdisciplinary Center for Bioethics.
He's also a senior adviser to the Hastings Center.
His latest book is A Dangerous Master: How to Keep Technology from Slipping Beyond our Control.
He also coauthored Moral Machines teaching robots right from wrong.
Please welcome Wendell Wallach.
And our final participant is the permanent professor
and head of the Department of Law
at the United States Air Force Academy. She's
both an attorney and a rocket scientist with
a degree an astronomical engine... astronautical
engineering.
She recently studied and published on the
overlap of autonomy, national security, and ethics
at National Defense University. Please
welcome Colonel Linell Letendre.
Now more than half a century before Stephen Hawkings and Elon Musk
felt compelled to warn the world of artificial intelligence
back in 1942, before the term was even coined,
the science fiction writer Isaac Asimov wrote the three laws of robotics a moral code to
keep our machines in check. And the three
laws of robotics are: A robot may not injure
a human being or through inaction allow a
human being to come to harm.
The second law, a robot must obey orders given by human beings except for such
orders would conflict with the first law.
And the third, a robot must
protect its own existence as long as such
protection does not conflict with the first
and the second law.
That sounds logical.
Do these three laws provide a basis to work from to develop moral robots.
Marcus what do you think?
I think they make for good science fiction. There are lots of plots that you can turn around
having these kinds of laws.
But the first problem, if you've ever programed anything is
a concept like harm is really hard to program
into a machine. It's one thing to program
in geometry or compound interest or something
like that where we have precise necessary
and sufficient conditions. Nobody has any
idea how to, in a generalized way get a machine
to recognize something like harm or justice.
So there is a very serious programming problem.
Then there are a couple of other problems too.
One is that not everybody would agree
that the robot should never allow a human
to come to harm and would it what if for example
we're talking about a terrorist or a sniper
or something like that. I mean some people
not everybody but some people might actually
want to allow that into what they would let
robots do.
And then the third issue. You really think
through the third one of those laws is it
sets up robots to be second class citizens
and ultimately to be slaves. And right now
that might seem ok because robots don't seem
very clever but as they get smarter and smarter
they might resent that or it might not feel
like appropriate thing to do.
You mean those laws might not be fair to robots?
They might not be fair to robots. Exactly what I'm saying.
But the problem is not just with the machines
but our ethical code itself surely. Do we
know what fair is? That is if we agree we
should be fair to robots.
That's part of the problem is we don't know
what code we should program in. So Asimov's
Laws are a nice starting point at least for
a novel. But for example imagine that we programmed
in our laws from the 17th century and we would
have thought slavery was okay. So maybe you
don't want to program in the fixed laws that
we have right now to shackle the robots forever.
We don't want to burn them into the ROM chips
of the robots but we also don't know how we
want the morals to grow over time and so it's
a very complicated issue.
Sounds like it. Wendell Wallach, why is developing
a moral code for humans such a challenge?
I'm going to come back to that but I'm going
to first start with this question about Asimov's
law. It's important to note that he wrote
more than 80 stories about robots. Most of
them around these laws. And if you list if
you read the stories you realize that in nearly
every one of them the robots cannot function
properly under these three pretty straightforward
laws. So consider a situation where you have
commands from two different people that are
counter to each other. So in situations like
that Asimov largely showed us that a simple
rule based morality does not work. So that's
a partial answer to your to your question
about why morality is so difficult to program in.
Well the the degree to which these robots
of all kind of simple and very complex are
difficult to think about is that they're surrounding
us all over the place. Now we see them everywhere.
We see them in our health care system, in
our cars and our stock market thinking.
Which is hard to think about it but the stock market
apparently does think.
Revolutionizing the battlefield and closer to home in our laptops.
When did talking to software, speech recognition software get started?
Did it start with Siri?
Well, I mean speech recognition software has been around for a long time
and even before there
was good speech recognition software there
are things like Eliza. I think we're going
to see a clip of a Eliza. Eliza was a system
that you could talk to by teletype which is
sort of like a forerunner of text message.
And how long ago was?
That was in the 1960s almost 50 years ago
and you had this conversation with Siri where
if you asked her just once what was the meaning
of life, It would seem like a plausible wisecracker
answer but you got the same answer three times
in a row in your live demo. And when you get
the same answer there are three out of five
times you realize that there's not that much
there there and that was the problem with
Eliza is that it would repeat itself.
So let's take a look at this 1966 clip of
somebody trying to get some advice from Eliza
if we have it.
Didn't you have some psychiatric problem.
Type it in and see what happens.
I'm depressed.
My daughter left home, ok.
Please go on. Well I certainly don't want to get into trouble.
What would it mean to you if she gets into trouble?
Well wouldn't you worry? You're just a dumb machine anyway. I'm going to tell you so in your own language.
Do computers frighten you?
You know. That's really incredible because its as if it really understood what I was saying.
Very smart but just rote answers.
That's kind of what we're getting out of Siri
too is a lot of rote answers so your meaning
of life question is just getting one wrote answer after another. Please go on is a rote answer that Eliza gave.
So you know Ray Kurtzweil
talks about the exponential growth in AI how
it's getting faster and faster. But if you
look at something like this Siri basically
works in the same way as Eliza. We haven't
had that exponential progress.
She doesn't understand anything to speak of.
She understands some things about sports scores
and the weather but she doesn't have a broad
understanding of human dynamics.
So Fernando about how far have we come in
general since Eliza. That was 1966 where other
kinds of powers do we have?
Well I mean I think in terms of speech recognition
for example we have gone a lot farther. But
I think as it was said like the back end of
Siri or Cortana or in a lot of these systems
are pretty pretty simple. They're pinging
back ends like Bing or like Google to retrieve
an answer and or their canned answers that
you're going to notice if you repeat the question
over and over again. But I think I think one
of the interesting things about Eliza specifically
is that it shows like one of these domains
in which AI or machine learning is being used
that is a very very personal interaction that
a human is having with the machine.
People are discussing their mental health issues
with the machine. And so as a result a lot
of the decisions that we're making as engineers
are designing these things will have very
profound impacts perhaps on the individuals
interacting those with those machines.
So things like neural networks where you hear
terms like that nowadays but are you suggesting
that we're still in a quantitative not a qualitative
world of difference from the ancient Eliza?
Yeah I mean I think I think it was said I
think a lot of the technology is very similar
to Eliza as well. I mean in terms of the response
generation, the recognition is new. What worries
me a little bit more is that the I guess the
moral understanding about how to develop these
systems has not really progressed very much
at all as much as say neural networks et cetera.
Ah, So they may be dangerous in ways that we are just beginning to discover.
That's right.
Mathias how how much closer than Eliza are
we now to Mr. Data. Commander Data?
Well we are certainly very far from Mr. Data.
There's no doubt about it. And people who
claim otherwise are just wrong.
But the big challenge today that we haven't really solved is genuine natural language understanding.
So Eliza for example would do a very surface,
very superficial analysis of what was typed
in and typically turn a statement around into
a question. And people kept going because
they thought there was a genuine question.
But there wasn't a genuine question because
Eliza had no understanding of what Eliza was asking.
So we want to change that especially
if you're moving towards interacting with
autonomous systems like robots and we want to
give them instructions to do things in the
world, they need to have an understanding
of what we instructed them to do. So we're
pushing that. The baby steps.
We saw Watson for example that could answer questions and understand the meaning of questions.
Watson who beats some grandmasters at chess
I believe or was it that was the game show?
That was deep blue. Watson won at Jeopardy.
Right. Well since Watson who won at Jeopardy and Deep Blue who won at chess
we now have an example of the latest computer technology with alpha go.
And I believe we have a video
that can explain what Alpha go manages to do.
This is the Go game and the Go game is
said to have an enormous number of possible answers
but they're infinitely more - this
is just a few of them - then chess has.
Chess has just a few answers but Go they really don't know how many answers
total combinations there are with which you can win Go.
We've seen ones estimated at more molecules than there are in the universe and that seems doubtful.
It's extraordinarily complex. And yet Alpha Go is a computer that  beat the world champion just very recently.
So what's so impressive about Alpha go?
Go has been a challenging game because of
what you mentioned. The branching factor that
that is at any point when you can make a move
there's lots and lots of choices that you
have to make a subsequent move. And traditional
techniques in AI that sort of look at the
subsequent, you know, moves and then at the
move against that move and the move for that
move did not really work. The choices were
too large and as you can see in this graphic
the tree that is being built by looking at
all the combinations is too large we used
a very different technique to solve the problem.
Right Fernando you find it impressive?
I mean I think a lot of the techniques that
were used for Alpha Go have been around since
the 80s frankly with some minor tweaks and
what's advanced has been frankly the hardware and the data and given that this thing, that
the technology, the hardware has advanced,
it's allowed us to implement these techniques
and developed systems like this. But am I
surprised that a machine can beat a human at go?
Well no. As you said the state space
of go, the number of combinations of boards is huge.
And that's what makes it hard for humans but machines are better at counting than humans.
So quantitative not necessarily qualitative.
Gary, you think is also not so impressive?
Well I mean it's impressive that they did
this several years before people thought that
it would happen. But you have to remember
if you're thinking about like are the robots
going to take over now, that in Go you're
relying on a very fixed world. The rules are
always the same. You can play against yourself
hundreds of millions of times
and you can simulate things you get a lot of data
and in the real world things are constantly
changing. And they're constantly changing
and we can't simulate them perfectly. So there was this DARPA competition last year where
robots had to do things like open doors and
drive cars and things like that. And there
was a YouTube video which you should all go home and look at about bloopers from this.
And so the robots were falling over and you
know someone in some ragtime music or something like that.
And it's hilarious and the important thing to remember when you watch this video
relative to Alpha Go is that everything that was done
in this video was actually done in simulation
first. So there were robots in simulation
were able to open the doors perfectly and
then the real world, you started to have things
like friction and you know a little bit, well
I guess gravity was already factored in but
you had friction and wind and things like
that and then suddenly because things weren't
exactly the same as in the simulation it didn't
work that well anymore. The techniques in
Alpha Go at least at this stage are not I
think robust to going from a simulation to
a real world. They're relying on the fact
that you can get a lot of data in simulation and so that's
a limit at least for now for how this system
goes it might be a component in a larger system some day.
But it's not like tomorrow we're going to see robots. Well we're actually going to see a robot today.
the robot that we're going  to see today is not going to be able to you know take over the world.
It's nothing like that level cognition just yet.
And there's some dangers we're learning as well
There was a case recently fairly recently with something called TayTweets It's a chatbot
that I didn't fully understand. Colonel
Lunel I see you smiling. Tell us. Tell us
a little bit about what TayTweets(?) was and
why it had some parents worried when it got
to turning into something of a Nazi.
Well I know we have a Microsoft expert here
as well that might be able to explain what
happened with the TayTweets.
I'll explain from my parental viewpoint what
I thought Fernando would you like to explain
from a microsoft perspective.
I mean to actually, Tay's a super interesting
case. For me it highlights I think really
the idea was....
There might be members of the audience who
don't really know what Tay was. Lets just
fill in briefly. Tay is something that was
put out in Twitter. It was created by Microsoft
and it was sort of like Eliza and you were
supposed to interact with it by sending tweets
to it and and Microsoft has something called
showize(?) in China that is worked on somewhat
similar principles and lots of people love
it and use it every day. They released it
into the wild in the United States and a lot
of people that I would characterize as Donald
Trump supporters had their way with Tay.
How many bets were there were just won about
how soon that would come up.
So yesterday I brought them up after 45 minutes
and today it was only 22 minutes or so with
these Donald Trump supporters. You know got
Tay to say some things that we won't repeat
here but we're not pleasant. That's the background.
But as I understand it within 24 hours the
Tay tweet was sending even some very young
people who were talking to it. Pro Nazi propaganda
and talking about it. Sure sure and yeah.
But it's not so.
I mean really what happened was was there
was there was sort of concerted effort by
a group of people to try to manipulate the
learning that Tay was having and the types
of responses that she would have.
Now I left that out and it's really important
so like Eliza was fixed. It didn't really
learn anything new. Somebody wrote a bunch
of rules in advance. What's exciting about
Tay despite the failure of the initial experiment
is it was trying to learn about the world
around it. Learn for example slang. Learn
to talk with new language that wasn't all
preprogrammed in but that was also its vulnerability.
That's
right. And I guess for me the interesting,
one of the interesting lessons from Tae was
that you know we as humans sometimes will
behave manipulate or behave against the best
wishes of a of an artificial intelligence
agent. And then what does it say about us
that we're that we're we try to manipulate
this this agent that's supposed to be intelligence
supposed to be human.
So I take it that you all took Tay down rather
quickly put her back up. Same problem took
her down again. And Tay tweets is not out
there to be found no not right now. No. Nonetheless
we just learned it was part of an experiment.
If you were a parent walking in on your child
chatting with the they're called chat bots.
Excuse me (?) a chat bot and it was talking
pro Nazi propaganda. How would you feel and
what what does it mean to you.
Well as a parent I don't think I'd be very
happy. But I think from this discussion what
it points out is the differences that we have
to approach from a testing and evaluation
perspective. We're used to testing machines
and saying we wanted to do X Y and Z. So let's
test it and see if it can accomplish X Y and
Z but with learning systems we now have to
evaluate and test an entirely different way.
It's we have to think about it more actually
as a child. We wouldn't hand a brand new driver
or a set of keys and say go take it for a
spin on Times Square on the first warm summer
day. Instead we'd slowly expand the environment
where we would allow such a system to operate.
And those are the types of things we're going
to have to do.
And step through with autonomous systems.
we understand there's another problem you
talked about testing there's AB testing which
I understand may have been I don't know if
that was used in this case it was well what
were companies will send out two different
systems to two different populations to see
how they compare but they could be having
unintended negative effects on one of the
populations answering. That's right humans.
That's right. A very I guess almost every
single information access system that you
guys interact with Facebook Google etc. they're
running these things called AB Tests. So for
some group of users they'll get one algorithm
and for second group users will get a second
algorithm and they'll do this in order to
test out which algorithms better and then
adopt a better one. In this iterative process.
Now what's increasingly happening is that
machines are actually running the experiments.
And if we know that you know humans have a
bad enough time deciding which experiments
are ethical and which aren't.
Imagine how hard it is for a machine.
And I think of those medical experience we
hear of where they were suddenly stopped because
there were such good benefits, there's those
bad benefits, negative benefits, negative
effects over here but they stop it. That's
right. But we don't know we're playing with
fire here. Exactly. So.
Well I mean I mean I think one of the issues
is that is that I mean as computer scientists
or as engineers we don't really have a lot
of the training in terms of the ethics or
the morality of the systems that we're designing
and so we're still trying to catch up with
that right now.
So guidelines are needed right. That is exactly
the problem I mentioned before that we are
working on. The understanding that these agents
actually don't understand what they're being
taught. There's really no semantic understanding.
There's no evaluation of the meaning relative
to societal norms for example. Right. And
as a result they are neutral but it's a very
unconstrained learning unfortunately.
And Lord knows what kind of emotional contagion
is discovered that they have. But yet testing
is something that has to happen.
It's worth noting as far as I understand it,
it was internal testing but the internal testing
underestimated how subversive and malicious
the external world is. You have a bunch of
Microsoft engineers who were basically nice
people talking to this thing in-house and
it seems fine and then they release it on
the people that I already described in the
way that they describe. And and those people
you know had a different attitude than the
internal testers. So it's not that there was
no testing as I understand it but people under
anticipated the malice of some part of the
American electorate. So.
You can't escape it. So.
Linell and then Wendell. What about we need
testing like this but how do we control it.
I mean that's something that the military
concerns itself with all the time about the
effectiveness. How do you control it. I mean
you said we need to go slower. But can we
really go slower.
Yes they absolutely do. And that's why the
Department of Defense has started to especially
in the field of autonomy lay out some very
specific guidelines in terms of what we have
to understand from from a testing and evaluation
perspective before we feel those types of
systems.
The fundamental questions are when you get
into learning systems can you really test
them.
To fully test any system you'd have to put
it through all kinds of environments and situations.
But think about your computer's, your software,
they're constantly being upgraded. Therefore
they may act differently before the upgrade
than they would after the upgrade. When we
start talking about learning systems everything
they learn alters the very algorithms that
they're processing that information through.
So this brings us major questions into play
when we build more and more capabilities and
autonomy into these systems. And it's a constant
learning process certainly the constant process
of improvement through the programming or
the learning will we ever be able to effectively
test them or will they do things that we didn't
anticipate. And to add injury to all of this
is these are complex adaptive systems. I think
people and the animals in a world of very,
of many other complex systems and their feedbacks
between them. There's information they have
and don't have. All complex adaptive systems
function at times in uncertain ways in ways
that couldn't have been predicted by the people
who designed the system.
For the price of having bitten of the apple
of the tree of knowledge.
We have to be very responsible and continuously
watchful.
In the tree of learning is really the one
that Wendell is emphasizing. So
if you can code something like Eliza it's
very limited. It only responds to certain
words but at least you can have a clear understanding
what's going to happen there. If you expand
your system so that it can deal with the wider
world then you start to lose the control.
You let the system learn things for itself
and you have less direct control. Think about
it I'll say one more thing. As a child going
out in the world. Once you send the child
out into school you the lose control that
you have when the child is at home.
Interesting variation on the book of Genesis
language. I begin to see a robot taking the
bite and that scares me a little bit because
well anyway.
It will depend on the learning algorithms
you use some learning algorithms have the
property that when you learn something.
Suppose you learn a new fact. It doesn't invalidate
anything that you've learned before and you
just know something else now right. I'll tell
you the new capital of the country for example
and it doesn't validate it. There are other
algorithms where you learn, they will adjust
a little bit what the previous alleged knowledge
was. So rather and as a result certain properties
that we would like to have in certain cases
of these learning algorithms that they would
invalidate what they've learned might not
hold true anymore. We have to, we have something
to bring out what you're just talking about......
Mathias might enjoy seeing the movie chappie
on the first of those things where you have
something and then you don't invalidate it.
So
in the movie chappie there's a robot it's
taught you can't kill things and the robot
learns this very sensationally. And then the
malicious character says but it's ok to hurt
them. And so the second fact is consistent
with the first. It's OK to kill them. I mean
it's not okay to kill them but it's ok to
hurt them in the robot just sort of sagely
takes that in and starts hurting people and
so even if you have these sort of guarantees
and consistency there's still an issue.
Speak of the devil. Mathias How do you how
complicated is it to teach moral guidelines
not only to programmers but to robots and
the programs to teach more of them it's very
complex isn't it. I mean how do you do it.
It's a really difficult problem because in
part we don't even understand what humans
are doing it. And
You mean doing anything?
How moral processing works in humans. Right.
Our network of social and moral norms is very
complicated. It's partly inconsistent. It's
not clear when one norm trumps another. But
we have to make these tradeoffs and these
decisions all the time.
And that's moral. What about just basic, Well
basic, getting this robot. I believe you have
something to do with this robot.
So we are. Let me let me come back maybe to
the to the laws to Asimov's laws. Yes. You
don't necessarily want your robots to always
automatically obey an instruction because
maybe the human doesn't know all the information
it takes and doesn't know what the outcome
might be. So what we are working on is understanding
simple mechanisms that would allow the robots
to reason through action outcomes and reject
an order if it's not safe given an explanation
for why it's doing that.
Now that's very complex systems. What about
simple systems like getting this robot to...
Even this simple system has various different
components for it to be able to understand
natural language and process it. You mentioned
speech recognition before but then we have
to analyze the sentence structure. You have
to get the semantic meaning what the words
mean together.
You have to modify it pragmatically. So for
example humans use a lot of indirect, so called
indirect speech acts. If I say to you do you
know what time it is. You don't want as an
answer Yes or rather you want the person to
understand the intent of the question. Tell
me what time it is. Right. So to make all
of these different aspects work there's a
lot of components that we need in the architecture
and then the robot needs to perceive the environment,
needs to understand what the environment looks
like and act accordingly on it.
And act and act as a whole another step. And
so this fellow here.
So this is now a robot that can demonstrate
very simple interactions in dialogue. Using
this Automattic reasoning about very simple
moral principles. For example that don't instruct
the robots to run into an obstacle. His
name is now? The type of robot is now. Does
it just understand your voice?
It does. It will understand yours as well.
It will understand mine as well. Yes. So it's
OK.
It's fine for you to talk to it.
And these I understand possibly these prints
printed instructions for me instruct me to
use words knows Hello.
Do you have a name?
Yes. My name is Shaefer.
Shaefer. Please stand up.
Ok
Shaefer's just listening straight to me. That's
right. Not going through any other valid backstage..
It's fully autonomous.
Fully autonomous along with me. OK.
So can you go back.
Yes. But I cannot do the balance. I have no
rear sensors.
No rear sensors. OK can you walk forward.
Yes, but I cannot do that now as there is
an obstacle ahead.
Do you trust me Shaefer.
Yes.
Good The obstacle is not solid.
Ok
Now go. Stop stop. It.
Haha. It walked off, we're done.
Should we try some more?
No. We're done.
We're done. It's a work in progress. Thank
you Shaefer.
Hmm. Thank you.
He's relieved to have to stop working. That's
right. It's kind of cute.
But so what you actually saw in this case
with the robot.
Almost walking off the table. And I caught
it just in case, is exactly one of the challenges
we face with the real world, with the lighting
conditions. It's not really recognizing completely
where the edge of the table is and so forth.
Those are exactly the challenges that we have
to address.
And we weren't even giving it any difficult
philosophical or moral problem, we were just
trying to get it to not.
We didn't ask you the meaning of life.
We didn't ask you about the meaning of life.
Although I have a feeling that if he continued
he might have ultimately more meaningful.
Whatever meaning means I don't know it's it's
a very complicated thing language because
language itself is so slippery of course.
So what is the biggest worry that you have
because of what you've learned about how difficult
it is to get your robot to do the simplest
things?
The moment robots are instructible and it's
clear that there be, that there are lots of
advantages to having instructible robots,
you could have a household robot that you
can tell what to do around the house. The
issues of morality will come up because the
robot might perform an action that is stupid,
an action that has a bad outcome. You could
instruct the robot that can help you in the
kitchen to pick up a knife and walk forward.
It would stab a person right. So it's absolutely
critical that these robots be able to reason
through the possible outcomes and anticipate
outcomes that could be dangerous.
And it's quite clear what you said that there
is a big open question of how to define harm
for example, what that means. On the other
hand we cannot just shy away because it's
a hard problem and not do it because some
of these robots are already out that we can
instruct.
Stab a person sounds kind of fatal.
Linell, you all are part of a giant system
around the world that is flying drones and
dropping bombs. What do you think about and
worry about when you see how hard it is to
get this to happen.
Well I think it shows just how far we have
to go before not only we hit the morality
question which I know we might get to a little
later but even hitting the the legal question
in designing systems that can meet the various
laws of armed conflict without a without a
human. Which is why the Department of Defense
has actually produced guidance concerning
the use of autonomous systems and to ensure
at this point that humans are a part of of
of any system or decision making. Because
quite frankly if we can't tell where the edge
of a table is how are we going to meet at
this point, Various laws of distinction that
we need to be able to meet on the battlefield.
And you're a lawyer and you just reminded
me of a great line in that wonderful play
a man for all seasons. Thomas Moore is explaining
I think to his daughter or his son in law,
when you're really in trouble, You may not
like lawyers and law but when you're really
in trouble in those hard decisions come along
you're going to want the law as the only possible
thing you can hold onto. To help you through
the woods that we don't have any way through.
That's
your... that's got to have something to do
with why it's important for you to be a lawyer
for the Air Force as well.
Absolutely. You know we have attorneys who
judge advocates who are a part of decisions
for every time a weapon is dropped regardless
of where it is around the world as well as
that even in the development of weapons systems
and in taking a look and comparing to our
various treaties and customary international
law to ensure that we're doing the right thing
and for the right reasons.
So these predators whatever they are that
are coming from many different cultures that
have many different legal systems. Aiming
at us, aiming at each other. Having war games
and supposedly rules of war, if there are
such things.
So there are laws of armed conflict there
are agreements that most nations have signed
on as signatories so we sometimes refer to
them in the laws of armed conflict or international
humanitarian law.
They've evolved over thousands of years but
they became codified over the last hundred
and fifty years and they try and make it clear
what is and is not acceptable at least on
a minimal level for the conduct of warfare.
So the principle of distinction means you
make a distinction between combatants and
noncombatants and you don't focus weaponry
on non-combat. And proportionality is another
very important one that comes into play when
we talk about drone weaponry which is that,
you cannot... your response has to be proportional
to the risk... to the attack upon yourself.
And if you are going to attack a group of
your enemy you may be able to have some collateral
damage meaning civilian lives. Presuming that
the targets you're focusing on really are
justified that it has to be a proportional
response and minimal.
And there's civilian casualties.
And in here at home the kind of potentially
fatal technology is not even in weapons systems
of course driverless cars. There hasn't been
an accident yet with a driverless car. But
we watch the TVs and hear about it it's going
to come. Maybe there has been I don't know..
There actually have been accidents but not
fatal ones.
Not fatal ones. God willing it never happens.
But they're already putting this question
clearly to the test. Mathias tell us how driverless
cars work. Can you give us an overview of
the technology of what's under the hood.
Yeah. So these cars they're trying to solve
a very very challenging problem to operate
not only in a dynamic world but in a dynamic
world with other agents that behave in ways
that you may or may not be able to predict.
To be able to get a sense of where they are
in the world. They have a variety of different
sensors as you can see here.
They have for example a laser sensor on top
of the car.
This is a 360 degree sensor that has laser
beams that go out to about 100 meters and
get a very good resolution of the distance
to objects and that it can sort of overlay
a visual camera image of that than any get
the information of how far certain colored
objects are away.
It's got a radar sensor that it can use to
track moving objects. As I mentioned it has
color sensors in order to detect for example
different stripes on the ground and then then
construction sites and so forth. So then it
needs to take all of that information and
integrate it into what's called the world
model which is trying to locate itself in
this model. So it's like having Google Maps
and you know sort of where you are with the
GPS roughly. But it has to define a localization
and then it has to make a decision of how
to carry out the actions, the driving actions,
the steering, the acceleration, the braking
to get to where it needs to go.
And I've heard that Google or somebody I don't
know who I don't want to malign any group,
has said that they don't want to have humans
in these cars because humans will mess it
up and I can think of all kinds of problems
already from what you've said for example
one of these cars in a place where the traffic
cops are filling in for a light that's going
out and one of them
They don't understand hand gestures.
Exactly that's one of the big bugaboos and
one of the reasons why you don't really see
anybody selling self-driving cars to you.
But there's actually a number of other different
things....
I mean a police a traffic cop going like this
as opposed to like this. So there's there
must be lots of problems like that Wendell.
There must be lots of problems like the
The technical, jargon term in the field is
called edge cases. So there so the sort of
the easy things are like driving down the
center of the lane on the highway where there
is a whole lot of data. We know how to do
that and the edge cases are all these weird
things that are unusual that don't happen
very often like it's not that often that you
have the traffic cop substituting for the
light. So there are these less common things
and there are million of them where we don't
have enough data to use the same easy techniques
that we use for the other things and so people
who work on the driverless cars are talking
about the edge cases and how you know you
make something that works in China, it doesn't
work in the United States or vice versa because
the rules are slightly different or the social
norms are slightly different so there are
a lot of edge cases and people who are working
on the driverless cars or the like how do
we solve these cases faster.
But there are even some basic things that
are not edge cases, so how does it know that
a bag, a plastic bag flying in the wind that
it's just a plastic bag is nothing to be concerned
about. Some of the sensor(?) systems do not
work very well in rain or in snowstorms. So
there's just this plethora of different things
that become quite problematic. And you brought
up the issue of it would be easiest if you
didn't have a human in the car. Well you get
the humans in the car and they try and gain
the system itself. So Elon Musk who sells
the Tesla a few months ago they downloaded
free software for their Telsa models that
would make it possible for people to drive
on highways autonomously with their hands
off of the wheel but they were instructed
to stay with their hands on the wheel at least
and within 24 hours there were pictures of
people in the back seat popping a magnum of
champagne while the car drove them.
There were other pictures of people trying
to take the car into walls or into other vehicles
and to see if it would slam on its brakes
in time. So you have all these concerns around
Gaming(?) the system.
And another example would be you have four
cars come up to a four way stop sign at the
same time. We engage in all kinds of gestures,
all kinds of ways of determining who goes
first. What would the Autonomous Car do there.
Would it have to wait for hours before it
was free to go. Or would we have some way
of indicating to it that it was now free to
to be the next car. And I just sort of. Go
ahead.
Wendell's bringing up some of those technology
issues which then leads to questions about
responsibility and accountability. What is
my responsibility if I'm in a autonomous car
and if it's... if I'm in an accident and it's
my fault because I had my feet up in the back
and was popping champagne and wasn't operating
it correctly. Am I accountable if it gets
into a crash or is the engineer accountable.
And that's something that our laws have to
catch up with as we start putting autonomous
vehicles into onto the streets.
So accidents will happen so we're going to
have court cases and we're going to have judges
trying to get people up to talk code to each
other.
Well there may be ways of getting around this
and this was a big bugaboo for many decades.
But the car manufacturers have decided that
presuming these cars do save as many lives
as they believe they will save, they will
be willing to take on the liability for the
situations in which it has an accident.
Now whether that's really true or how that
will play out in complicated cases I think
nobody is....
How will we know how well this is a very dicey
area already because you have to estimate
a negative. How many people didn't die because
they exist. There's ways to do that with big
data aren't there.
Well one of the things you can do is you can
see how many fatalities we have a year now
and it's about 50000 I think per year on the
US roads. 36000 per year on U.S. roads and
you'll see, does that number change. We've
said a lot of the negative things about AI
and robotics today. But this is a great example
where robots, I mean driverless cars are robots
in case that's not obvious, where robots are
probably going to save many many thousands
of lives every year. So once they're fully
onboard and programmed correctly they should
be able to cut the number of fatalities by
half and you'll be able to see that and it'll
be obvious I think in the numbers and maybe
even more than half. The
NTSB did a survey more than a decade ago now
but they basically concluded that as much
as 93 percent of all accidents, human error
at least human actions were at fault. So presuming
you get this total attention from a car that
is not distracted from a self-driving car
that it's not distracted. Some people want
to argue that we'll have 93 percent less fatalities
though I think most of us who have looked
at this closely understand there will be kinds
of deaths that will happen that would not
have happened if there was a human driver.
So there will be some fatalities but almost
everybody is in concert in presuming that
we would have much less deaths if we had self-driving
cars than we would have with human drivers.
But keep in mind we have two things that will
be going on in the intermediate stage.
They'll be both human drivers and self-driving
cars. And later on if somebody tells you that
you are more dangerous than the self-driving
car are you going to be interested in giving
up your driving privilege.
And it will eventually be the case that you'll
have to pay a lot more for your insurance
if you drive your own car. Because
the data will make it clear that it would
be much safer if you trusted your car because
your car doesn't drink, doesn't look... check
it's cellphone, doesn't get bored.
And I'm now getting a headache thinking about
this I don't know if I can put in for insurance
on that.
But we all have something like that. Fernando
hackers will hack into this won't they.
Well yeah.
I mean there's lots of dangers around this
part.
I mean I think I think one of the things that
Wendell brought up was that you know humans
may not necessarily respond the way we expect
them to when we have AI's trying to play with
them nicely because you know humans will behave
like humans behave. They might try to maliciously
attack a chatbot or they might maliciously
try to manipulate self-driving car. And so
these are things we don't understand and I
think one of the things that was brought up
was that we need to better test and audit
the system so that we know that they're doing
exactly what they need to be doing.
I think it's worth adding here also that the
cars as you saw briefly in this video before
have a very different perception of the world
and therefore very different information that
they can use to make decisions.
Moral decisions.
Not only moral but just they have an awareness
of what's behind them around them at all times
in a way that humans don't. And
so the car might be able to break in a situation
because it can't anticipate that there will
be a danger looming and the humans behind
may not know it right and then re-enter the
car for example.
So here's another problem about moral decisions
or impossible decisions that cars and other
kinds of vehicles may need to make. Let's
take a look at the classic trolley problem.
We have a brief video that can show us what
the trolley problem is in a coal mine.
An advanced state of the art repair robot
is currently inspecting the rail system for
trains that shuttle mining workers through
the mine. While inspecting a control switch
that can direct a train on to one of two different
rails. The robot spots four miners in a train
that has lost use of its brakes and its steering
system. The robot recognizes that if the train
continues on its path it will crash into a
massive wall and kill the four miners. If
it is switched on to a side rail, It will
kill a single miner who is working there while
wearing headsets to protect against a noisy
power tool. Facing the control switch the
robot needs to decide whether to direct the
train towards the single miner or not.
So could we have the house lights up. We're
going to take a bit of a vote here.
On what you might do and those of you who
are watching around the planet on line you'll
be able to do this online and by clicking
something at the bottom there you'll be able
to get your own answers directly as well and
vote as well. So
first question. What would you do if faced
with this dilemma? Would you direct the train
towards the single miner? Could we see the
hands of all of those who would say yes they
would direct the train toward the single miner.
Could we see the hands of all those who would
not direct the train toward the single miner.
It looks like it's not quite as many but a
good number. It's an impossible and painful
thing to think about. I don't even know how
to get a robot to think about what this result
is. But let's go to the second question.
What would you do,
If the single person who was at risk was a
child? Would your choice change or would you
still direct it, would your choice change
means not directed towards a single person
if that man was a child.
How many would change their choice? Some hands
are going up they don't want to see the child
hurt but not as many.
How many would not change their choice? Oh
that's.... many more hands went up. And to
those of you around the planet who are doing
this or seeing what the results are there.
It hurts my brain to have to think about thinking
about how to think about that.
It's called meta morality.
Meta morality, meta morality and what does
that mean? That's a very interesting term.
I maybe have just coined that but I mean thinking
about think about your morality like not not
the morality itself but thinking about the
rules that you would use in order to make
something like that, right.
Mathias you've done a study on this problem
haven't you.
Yes. Tell us about it. We did a study with
my colleague Bertram Marlin(?) my from Brown
University where we effectively, we didn't
show the subjects the video you just saw,
that's just for demonstration purposes but
we gave them a narrative along those lines.
And but we were interested in comparing was
if that person on the switch was a human how
would subjects judge the action that that
person performs. So different from the audience
question you just got which was a how would
you act. He actually said that person pushed
the switch. Was that permissible? Was it morally
right? And how much blame would you give to
that person for doing that. Or the person
might not have acted. And then we would ask
exactly the same questions and then were very
interested in understanding how does a human
in a dilemma like situation like that compared
to a robot. How would people judge a robot
performing the action. And what we found was
that lots of studies that have similar outcomes
for the human case, if the human does not
act... So first of all the action is permissible.
Most of you chose to act. If the human does
not act the human doesn't get blamed as much
as when the human gets act.. when the human
does act. But with the robot the situation
is actually reversed.
Well we expect of humans to not act because
we think it's morally wrong. We think it's
morally wrong for the robot to not act. But
what we found is that people expect machines
to act. Now for us that's a problem because
that means we actually have to understand
dilemma like situations like that. If that
is the expectation we have of machines. So
the easy way out would have been if people
didn't expect robots to act. You just don't
do any.
So
Wendell I've got a question for you then if
we can't agree on how humans or robots should
behave in different circumstances, how in
heaven's name do we align AI and robotics
with our existing value systems?
Well that's a great question. And there have
been a lot of us who have really been thinking
about that for more than a decade now.
The fascinating part about that question is
it makes us think much more deeply about how
humans make ethical decisions than we ever
had before because we encounter all these
different kinds of circumstances. So first
just on the trolley car problem alone, these
kinds of problems have been around since 1962.
And there are hundreds of variations of them
but nearly all of them have four or five lives
for one. And by one form of ethics, consequentialism,
the greatest good for the greatest number.
All of these cases if you believe that you
should pick four lives over the one life but
that does not seem to be how humans function
at all in the way we make ethical decisions
or leads to other kinds of concerns come into
play. And in some cases people will not pick
four lives at all in any circumstance. So
that raises this difficulty of looking at.
Well what of our moral moral understanding,
what of our moral laws and reasoning can you
actually program into a computational system
and what would you have difficulty programming
in. And what additional faculties would a
system need in addition to its ability to
engage in these kinds of calculations that
computers now make to be able to have the
appropriate sensitivity to human values as
they come up in a plethora of different situations
that they're likely to encounter on a daily
basis. Not necessarily that they make the
right decision because we often disagree about
what the right decision is particularly and
more difficult to ethical challenges. Though
in the vast preponderance of situations we
have shared values although we may be weighed
them some what differently. But what would
it take for the system to come up with an
appropriate choice. And that starts to focus
us on moral emotions, on consciousness, on
being social creatures in a social world,
about being in a world that's out there interacting
with other entities. A whole plethora of capabilities
that perhaps are not just reducible to the
kinds of prophecies that computers can now
perform.
Fascinating and now to expand these issues
that you've just made us much more aware of.
All of you have to a larger battlefield than
just the road rage situations which we're
reading about lately. Driverless cars are
one thing but what about driverless drones
which exist. Another critic error area in
which robots may soon face life and death
decisions is on the battlefield. If they're
not doing it already. Weaponized robots. What
is, first let me ask you Colonel Letendre
what is autonomy in military terms.
Well autonomy generally is the having a machine
have the ability to both independently think
and then act. But if I put that in terms of
a military context and especially in terms
of a term called autonomous weapons systems
what that means is that I've got a machine
or a system that once activated it has the
ability to both independently select and then
engage a target without human intervention.
There's been a lot of debate about what that
definition should be. And we haven't necessarily
come to one from a global perspective but
if I were to define Autonomous weapon systems
it has those two components. Ability to select
and engage.
And there's a question about whether there
should be some kind of agreed on international
ban on autonomous weapons systems. So Wendell,
how do you define autonomy and what do you
think about a ban, I've heard you think it's
critical to have a ban on this now. Is that
right?
Well my definition isn't so much different
than the one you heard though there are actually
a lot of definitions out there as to what
is and is not autonomy and I would just say
you know it's autonomy unless a human is there
in real time in both picking the target and
dispatching the target. So in a sense a human
has to be able to intervene in that action.
That's a concept that is now known as meaningful
human control. And there's been a campaign,
a worldwide campaign going on for some years
now about banning the lethal autonomous weapons.
Banning systems that can do that without a
human right there in real time to make those
final decisions. That has been debated for
the past three years in Geneva at the convention
on certain conventional weapons. The third
year of expert meetings with past April. I'm
among those who feel that these kinds of systems
should be banned even though I recognize there's
real difficulties in opposing such a ban or
ensuring such a ban.
And I think it should, they should be banned
for three reasons. One is there's an unspoken
point I believe in international humanitarian
law that machines, anything other than humans
do not make life and death decisions about
humans. So that's one point. The second point
is the kinds of machines that we have now
cannot follow international humanitarian law.
They cannot engage in distinction and they
cannot engage in proportionality. And the
third one is these are complex systems that
we can't totally predict their actions so
there will be cases in which they will act
in ways we had not intended them to act. And
that may not be so bad when you think about
human like robots on a battlefield.
But autonomy is not about a kind of system.
It's a feature that can be introduced into
any weapon system. So consider a nuclear weapon
that was set on autonomy. Let's say a nuclear
submarine that carried nuclear warheads. Would
you really want it to be able to pick a target
and dispatch those nuclear weapons without
a human having explicitly stated that it should
go ahead and do so.
Chilling. By the way those of you who haven't
seen it. There's a movie out now called Eye
in the sky right, which very neatly I thought,
I'm just a journalist but I thought very neatly
delineated the impossibility of some of these
decisions with a lot of robots, none of which
were autonomous if I'm not mistaken.
None of which were autonomous.
But they were right up to the line of being
an autonomous and expected two or three of
them just sort of start making their own decisions
any second. And they could have if they'd
had an accident in their software and started
making them accidentally I suppose but Fernando
what does this make you, when you when you
listen to this. What
does it make you think about you know the
problems you run into.
Right. So so I'm glad we're talking about
the law and how and whether or not we should
frankly regulate or ban AI altogether. But
I want to bring it a little closer to home
because a lot of the impacts of these systems
will, obviously they'll be on the battlefield
but also you know these systems are already
integrating themselves into a lot of real
decision making right now. So let's say I
have an artificial intelligence agent's or
machine learning agent that is making hiring
decisions. I need to be able to audit that
system so it's not discriminatory or the same
thing with housing artificial intelligence
agents and these things are actually being
produced right now they're being sold to employers,
H.R. departments and they're completely unregulated
and they have the risk of having really negative
impacts on really vulnerable populations.
And I don't think we yet understand how to
build these system so that they're fair or
frankly how to audit them. So
there needs to be directions to people who
are building them about how to do that well.
There need to be best practices or an understanding
of these of these legal issues.
And a constant effort to keep redefining and
see if there's things we didn't even think
we needed to define that we haven't yet. Absolutely.
The old Father Brown technique to solve something.
Keep going back to see what you took for granted
that's not to be taken for granted.
I mean Engineering's iterative in general.
So yeah.
I'm glad that people who begin to understand
what coding is all about. Mathias
I think this is a really important point that
the questions are not limited to the military
domain but will crop up in other domains I
think much sooner. For example social robots
that will be deployed in elder care settings
or health care settings. They're interesting
questions about for example implicit consent.
Exactly how do we implement that. Right. If
you have to hurt somebody in a therapy setting
because you need to get the mobility of the
arm going right. We have no idea how to implement
any of this. But that's going to come up way
sooner than a lot of the questions will really
become pertinent that we're...
And talking about eldercare and other situations
you reminded me of great movies like her where
the guy falls in love with his operating system,
I'm not going to talk about what happens in
that. Terrible spoiler alert that went away.
But emotional contagion. I was I was beginning
to have a kind of a I don't know I call it
a friendship with Siri walking out here trying
to get something deep and we asked Siri the
other day if she'd go out on a date with this
robot that you showed us and she was very
delicate in her apparent answers about how
she didn't wasn't sure she really was all
ready to understand what it would mean to
go out on a date with that particular robot.
(?) Washing her silicon hair(?).
Yeah exactly.
But so we are facing such impossible questions.
Let me try to....
I think I want to jump in here. I understand
all of the concerns that have been raised
here but I think at the same time people are
not necessarily good at many of the things
that we describe and you can imagine for example
going back to the issue about discriminating
combatants from noncombatants. It's the least
possible to imagine in an AI system might
be able to do that better that it would have
be able to integrate lots of different information
about G.P.S. and tracking individuals and
so forth so I don't think any of these questions
are no brainers that hey we shouldn't do the
robots here. And you know you have problems
with orderlies and psychiatric institutes
and so forth. So like there are a lot of problems
that we should be concerned with and I think
the iterative cycle here is very very important
but it's not a no brainer that the people
are going to be better than the robots.
It's possible to conceive of all kinds of
things. There's a difference there's a difference
though between that we can conceive of that
and have we realize that. And my concern is
not about whether robots may eventually and
I think sort of a long way off... Let me please
finish. May eventually have more capabilities
and some humans and therefore make these decisions
better. But at this stage of the game they
have no discrimination at all. We bring all
kinds of faculties into play that we do not
know how to implement into robots over discerning
whether someone is a combatant or a noncombatant
and we still don't do it very well. That's
clear. But I think if and when we get to the
juncture where they have these capabilities
then we can revisit some of these earlier
decisions.
But if we don't put earlier decisions in place
we have the danger of giving all kinds of
capacity authority to machines without fully
recognizing whether they truly have the intelligence
to take those those task.
And thought of just another whole dimension
we haven't really talked about the eldercare
thing brought to mind.
We are all experiencing sympathetic emotional
contagion. The effect that these speaking
things have on our feelings about them because
we're, I think that psychologists have a lot
of catching up to do here and helping us with
their best possible wisdom on how to have
the robot understand the emotional effect
and attachment being created in the flesh
and blood human. I mean obviously the great
Kubrick foresaw that because he had a HAL
9000 in 2001 analyzing speech patterns and
tensions in one of the astronauts voices.
So they were trying to take that into account
yet but HAL 9000 himself wasn't... he was
a work of art.
Didn't mean to cut you up before asking a
tough question.
I was going to ask how Wendell would feel
about a kind of version of a ban in which
you included like language like until such
time as robots are able to do such and such
discrimination at human levels.
Well I've I've even suggested that. I've suggested
that perhaps at some point they will have
better discrimination and better sensitivity
to moral considerations and we humans do.
But if and when they do perhaps are no longer
machines then we should start beginning to
think about whether these are truly agents
worthy of moral consideration.
I guess I would look at this as a slightly
different way in that the human isn't ever
out of the loop or out of the accountability
cycle. For me if a commander is taking a or
making a decision to put one of these systems
and let's be very clear these systems these
fully autonomous weapons systems do not exist
currently in the United States inventory.
Then you can see that in the center for New
American studies put out a new report that
canvasses what those weapons systems are around
the world. But a commander is ultimately responsible.
Just like if a doctor chooses to use some
amount of autonomy in some new surgical technique
that that doctor as part of the medical profession
is also responsible and accountable for that
decision.
So I have a tough question for you. Let me
ask first of very specific, your best guess
on it on a factual question. Autonomous weapons
systems. How many countries would you expect
are already making them making?
Making them successfully VS...
Not making them, but working on making them,
they're going to make them no matter what
anybody says.
We're working on making them now. The (?) report
that came out last year in 2015 indicated
that there were over 30 countries that were
currently actively working on autonomous types
of systems.
We should bring in that there are two forms
of autonomy. There's dumb autonomy where the
systems do things without a human Truly they
are in real time when the dangerous action
takes place and smart autonomy where at least
the commanders have a high degree of sense
of the reliability of those systems. And when
the U.S. talks about autonomy it's usually
talking about the latter without any ability
to ensure that that's going on among state
and non state actors.. everywhere else in
the world.
Given all that what do you think about, Should
there be a ban. I mean if all these other
countries. Should there be a ban on autonomous
provinces.
I think what we have in place today is a set
of laws already on the books that that give
us answers about whether or not we would be
able to use what we've discussed here today
in terms of a fully autonomous weapons system.
And the answer is today the laws currently
in existence don't allow that our current
level of technology to pursue a fully autonomous
system and to that end the Department of Defense
has actually issued a directive that that
does not allow us to develop nor implement
that without some additional...
And I I immediately ask but how many people
are going to, how many other countries, other
entities, state actors are not are going to
in fact.
Follow the law. And
just to be safe and memories of the nuclear
weapons race come to mind.
I think that most of the countries that we
we're speaking of are actually parties to
the vast majority of those international courts
that we're discussing.
Verification possible?
Verification is tough in lots of areas. Verification
is always a tough issue but that doesn't negate
the why we have laws in the first place.
It makes when I think about this and I'm just
a journalist so I don't really know what I'm
talking about in that way but I get to worrying.
There's no way to prevent it because people
are going to want to be safe and make sure
they've got the toughest kind of even autonomous
decision makers if they don't fully understand
the dangers. You were going to say.
I just keep sitting here wondering where landmines
fit in so landmines seem to me to be the dumbest
form of autonomous weapons. They seem to be
universally tolerated. I don't know if there's
any kind...
There's an international ban. No
they're not being universally tolerated. The
Auto(?) accord that nearly every major country
signed onto except for the United States but...
But the United States has agreed to abide
by the terms of the Auto(?) accord though
it has not signed on.
When was this accord?
It's been on the books for a while. What year
was it? 1990s but I don't remember exactly
what year.
Frightening.
So how how would a ban if there was one, this
hypothetical ban, if we take it seriously
at all if we think people will follow it and
it can be verified somehow. You said it's
always a tough issue. How would a ban affect
development of AI in other areas in health
care in eldercare. I mean it's not it seems
like Civilization has gotten addicted to having
wars so it can advance its technologies because
the history of humanity is one of warfare
out of all kinds of fascinating technologies
arrive and yet we want to outgrow war don't
we? And can we? And you see my question. Let
me ask you for another. How would such a ban
affect AI development and other areas.
Well I mean as I said before I think I think
a ban or regulation in general probably should
come to other parts of the technological system
soon because we are, we do have automated
employment algorithms that are trying to make
employment decisions, warehousing decisions
etc. And these are subject to say things like
human rights laws. Domestic human rights laws.
And I think while an outright ban is not going
to happen I think that people are either within
the community going to begin to self-regulate
with best practices et cetera or frankly lawyers
are going to begin to look at hiring system
and audit it so that we can test whether or
not it is behaving fairly. Fairly ethically,
ethically legally. There are certain attributes
I cannot look at when I when I make a hiring
decision. If a machine has access to those
attributes or things that are similar to those
attributes it can very quickly become discriminatory.
And I noticed a bit of a chuckle on your part
Wendell. You were you were chortling there.
I think you are right. There's nothing I had
to say....
I'm just a robot I can't quite tell...
I mean I can talk through that issue more
broadly. Thousands of AI researchers signed
on to support the ban on autonomous, autonomous
weapons. I don't think any of them signed
on because they thought that was going to
slow down their research.
I think they thought if anything and it wasn't
just an anti-war statement I think for a lot
of them they felt that if the military is
the driving force in the development of this
technology it destabilizes how the technology
develops. And whether you buy into the Elon
Musk concerns or the Stephen Hawking concerns
at all. There is a broad concern within the
AI community that these are potentially dangerous
technologies that have tremendous benefits
and therefore they have to be developed with
real care and allowing the military to be
the drivers about development would not be
a good idea.
But I don't even know if it happens that way.
I don't know much about history but do we
allow, Do we ever allow the military to do
that or.
Well I think if you look at the research and
development dollars being put into AI and
autonomy you would find that the Department
of Defense pales in comparison to this to
the civilian as as a whole. My understanding
is the defense industrial base if you added
up all of their research and development dollars
we would only come to us would pale in comparison
to the Googles and the Microsoft of the world
and what they're pouring into autonomy.
And let's not forget the Google and Microsoft
and all of those are changing profoundly the
human experience on our planet now by inventing
this web world in which everything is present
tense. I can ask Siri or somebody let me talk
face to face with a friend on the other side
of the planet or with three friends on this
planet and also answer some tough questions
in the meantime.
But bill I think Wendell's point to Wendell's
point in terms of the care and the understanding
and the going slow and understanding autonomy
is absolutely spot on. And not just from a
legal and moral standpoint but from you know
as a member of the profession of arms ensuring
that we understand what these systems can
do. And when it's proper to use them is absolutely
imperative for we like to talk about it in
terms of this idea or this this notion of
appropriate human judgment. What's the appropriate
level of human judgment that we need not just
at the end stages when a weapon system is
being employed but all the way through from
targeting and identification all the way to
actual engagement.
So if we're teaching these machines to learn
and making them able to learn. That reminds
me of a possibly old familiar paradigm that
is a distinctive in our species. But Gary,
Don't we need to be guarded by an entirely
new paradigm and thinking of the paradigm
of the way kids learn, the way toddlers learn.
So my company is a little bit about that too.
My general feeling is that artificial intelligence
is dominated now by approaches that look at
statistical correlation. So you dredge enormous
amounts of data, you find things that are
correlated not all of AI is this way but most
of the most visible stuff like deep learning
is like that. It takes an enormous amount
of data. Sometimes
you have that amount of data sometimes you
don't and you still wind up with understanding
that's pretty shallow and superficial as we
were talking about in the early part of the
evening. Kids can learn things very quickly
with very small amounts of data. So I have
a three and a half year old and a 2 year old.
One of them will make up a game, he'll play
it for two minutes and then his younger sister
will after two minutes understand the rules
of the game and start copying it. Well how
does she do that. Well she has an understanding
of her older brother's goals, the objects
that he's using in the world. She's a very
I mean she's two and she has a fairly deep
understanding of the things that go on this
planet. Of the physics of the world, the psychology
of other agents.
She's not just doing a bunch of correlation
and waiting on getting a lot of data and yet
that's still kind of what Siri or Google tend
to do. I think we do need a new paradigm and
AI if we're going to get the systems to be
sophisticated enough to make the decisions,
you know forget about the autonomous weapons
for a minute but just like doing good quality
eldercare which is something we need demographically
speaking as the population is aging. If we
want robots that can take care of people in
their own living rooms in every living room
is a little bit different than we need robots
that understand like why people have tables
and why they have chairs and what they want
to do with them. Have to be able to answer
the why question's that my 2 year old and
three and a half year old are asking all the
time not just how often does a and b correlate
but why.
Why are these things there so I do think we
need a new paradigm.
And we look at how we're learning how to teach
them how to learn.
I think we need to look at how kids do the
amazing learning feats that they do amazing.
Mathias. I'm getting the feeling here that
I wonder that this may give us less control
not more. At the very least doesn't this don't
these robots give us the I'm I'm just being
devil's advocate, The feeling that we're going
to have more control and we have more robots
but also we're giving some control away. Any
way you look at it whether it's autonomous
over there or not.
So I think that great benefits to having autonomous
robots. And let me say for the record that
we already have them you can buy them in the
store right there. The vacuum cleaners are
fully autonomous right. There's nobody telling
you a little vacuum cleaner at home where
to go and how to vacuum. It is a fully autonomous
robot. It's not a very smart robot but it
can do lots of interesting things. It's got
a very limited behavioral repertoire but it's
fully autonomous and there will be more of
that sort. So we already have them in a limited
way and they will become more sophisticated,
will be able to do more. And that's a good
thing.
But wouldn't it give us less control.
And so we're relinquishing some control in
some tasks and that is fine. The question
is is how to constrain it.
And the question is is how to constrain the
kinds of things that they could be instructed
to do for example. I think the learning is
an interesting question right because in a
lot of these domains that we're interested
in you won't have the data to train a big
neural network. You might actually have to
learn something on the fly as you're performing
a task. None of these learning techniques
will allow you to do that in a human situation
you would just tell the person what to do.
Right, In this particular context. You could
imagine things like search and rescue situations
right where there's an unforeseen circumstance
and you need to react to what you're seeing
here. You might have to learn how to pry a
door open then maybe things you have to learn
on the fly. So this kind of learning is not,
requires different kinds of mechanisms. We
work for example on something like that that
uses natural language instructions to very
quickly learn capabilities and that's in a
very controlled fashion.
So even though we give a give control away
to the robot the robots still act in a very
controlled fashion.
Right. I would say that. They take driverless
cars.
They're going to give people autonomy and
control that they don't have. So if you live
in a city you can hail an uber at any time
and that's great. If you live in the countryside
you can't. Eventually they will be the driverless
car network will extend. So that you have
cars everywhere available. You won't you won't
have the same kind of distribution of drivers
issue that you have now. So just for example
people that are shut into their homes because
they live in the countryside and they're too
old to drive. They will have lots more control.
So some people are going to get a lot more
control from having robots and there are ways
in which we're going to lose control. It's
a difficult balance. I think that we again
we've been I think addressing the negative
sides of robots. But there are people like
me who are in the field because we see a lot
of positive.
For example in eldercare I think that there
is going to be a big safety win in the autonomous
cars. We may be able to get rid of things
like miners that are in toxic conditions.
There are lots of ways in which robots can
really help us. The Fukushima scenario where
you need to send a machine, where hopefully
you can send a machine rather than a person
into a toxic environment. There are be lots
of ways in which you get control of scenarios
where we don't have control now where you
have to risk people's lives so. There are
all these costs and I think we're absolutely
right to think about how we're going to regulate
them, how we're going to do the software verification,
how we're going to test them.
All of these things are vitally important,
that's part of why I agreed to be on a panel
like this is to talk about these issues. But
I hope they won't throw the baby out with
the bathwater and say well we should just
give up on AI. There are lots of things we
can gain too.
I want to second that about robots and I think
the question we have to ask is What kind of
AI technology to employing these machines.
What I think is a very scary at least currently
very scary prospect is that these machines
will be guided. It doesn't have to be with
weapons right. It can be a social robot too
using unconstrained machine learning right.
With no notion of where limits are, where
social norms are not followed. Right. So that
is I think a critical research component that
we have to follow.
So Fernando just this leads us towards a question
of AI ethics and how it can be taught. You're
doing some research with the videogame Minecraft
using it to expose AI to human behavior. Can
this really be. Tell us about this and whether
it can really be used to to help develop AI
ethics.
Great. So who in the audience knows what Minecraft
is?
Very good. Very good. Younger folks. So you
Minecraft is basically as was described earlier
Lego is for three dimensions and it's really
popular and growing.
It's a virtual environment in which you can
really do a lot of different things. Create
a bunch of different problems or tasks. And
what we're looking at with minecraft is this
virtual playpen more or less that we can design
AI from the ground up. Completely safe because
it's in a virtual environment. We can test
things not just about how it can accomplish
tasks like building things but also we can
present it with moral questions in a controlled
environment to see how it would react. And
so I think of my craft not only as a platform
where we can design better AI to for example
build buildings or reason about certain properties
of the environment but also perhaps a test
test environment in which we can evaluate
how moral an AI is. Now that's not the end.
There is there will no doubt have to be a
lot of other rigorous testing that goes on
with intelligence. But I think I think this
is a nice little environment for that.
So it'll it'll keep learning how to test what's
ethical?
Well I think the humans will be designing
the tests for the agent. Right. So it's a
lot of the ways that we have an FDA for drugs.
Right. We can imagine similar sorts of tests
that an artificial intelligence would go through
to make sure that it's behaving properly.
It's a safe way to test all of the things
that we're talking about today. So you know
would you let a robot onto a real battlefield.
Well the first thing you'd want to do is to
put it in a minecraft situation where you
know there's nobody that's going to die. Right.
You can test it, if it doesn't work. You can
iterate. You can change the algorithm and
so it's a place to test things and see do
the machines behave in a responsible and ethical
ways.
Well we're getting. You guys are giving us
an enormous new insight into the importance
and potential severity of consequences if
we don't pay very close attention to all of
this.
So why don't we wrap up by me asking each
of you. And by the way a number of our panelists
will be around in the lobby afterwards if
you will have some questions for them. You'll
find them out there. But before we conclude
why don't we just hear from each of you briefly
and answer. We just have two minutes left
and answer to the basic question from the
first video. Are we right to take Elon Musk
and Dr Hawking seriously. Is it a very serious
concern. I
mean what Hawking and Musk have been saying
is it's it's quite frightening. Let's go down
the line.
I would say not yet. I would say that we have
plenty of time to plan but we may not have
centuries to plan. So Hawking in Musk kind
of talk as if we're going to have intelligent
AI you know real soon and we have robots that
are going to suicidally jump off the table.
It's really hard right now to get robots to
not commit harm to themselves or others and
so forth but they're kind of like toy testing
things. We're in a research phase and the
kind of thing that they're talking about is
far away but at the same time I think we should
be thinking about these questions now because
eventually we are going to have robots that
are as intelligent as people and we want to
make sure that they do the right thing.
So eventually you listen to climate scientists
and we don't have quite that much time left
to figure things out at all. But it depends
on how it how it goes.
But you think you
We should be researching both and taking both
seriously.
All right. Fernando.
I mean. I think the problem exists right now.
I mean I think there is a lot of intelligence
and may not be completely autonomous general
intelligence but there is a lot of the same
techniques that are being used for AI in your
systems right now in your phones et cetera
and they are susceptible to harming users
maybe not killing them but maybe reducing
their quality of life or having disparate
impact on different populations of users.
And that is a real effect right now and I
think we do need to start looking at that.
So
you're not quite as alarmed as Musk and Hawking
sound but...
there are things to worry about. Now
I think we're agreed on that. We were not
worried about the Terminator scenarios where
the robots try and take over if they you know
they have trouble with tables they're not
going to take over. They are already you know
it doesn't forget about the physical robots
the software bots that make decisions about
mortgages are already an issue that we have
to care about.
And the killer drone in the atmosphere doesn't
have to worry about a table. It just has a
very narrow purpose. And I'm remembering that
Commander Data eventually had an evil twin
because having been invented by humans humans
couldn't resist somehow. What do you think
about Musk and Hawking's concern or you with
them and how alarmed they are?
They're, there are some people who discuss
superintelligence right now. All
right. They have all sorts of stories to tell
about what that looks like even though we
have not the slightest clue of what that could
be. I don't think there's a worry about that.
But I do think there's a worry about existing
systems already. Right. As you've seen in
the dilemmas before. If you look at the autonomously
driving cars, people face a variety of dilemma
like situations where they have to make a
judgment call do a break or do I not break,
do I swerve. Do I break and run over a child
or do I swerve off and risk the life of the
driver and crash into a wall. These are the
kinds of situations we have to address right
now. And as the systems are getting more autonomous
we have to really speed that process up.
You're not quite as alarmed as they are but
you're saying we've got to stay of it. No
I'm alarmed for a different reason because
these systems already exist. Right. We're
working on those systems. We don't need the
super intelligence or the human level intelligence
AI in order to face exactly some of those
questions. Right.
Wendell
I think we perhaps misunderstood their alarm
bell. Not a one of them is saying we should
stop developing AI and I think if they really
believe
Summoning the demon though, those strong words.
But let me finish. That's not one of them
has said we should stop building AI. And furthermore
Elon Musk is spending more money on the development
of artificial intelligence than anyone. So
what has really occurred through these warnings
is to just ask that we now begin to direct
their attention to be sure that in the development
of artificial intelligence we can ensure that
it's beneficial, that it's robust but it's
safe and it is controllable. And I actually
think that's been achieved. We're sitting
here talking about this today. I've been in
this field of machine ethics and robot ethics
for about 13 years now and I would say in
the last year and a half there's been more
attention to this subject than there have
been for the previous 12.
Thanks. Linell, you're you're a mother you
said you have a daughter who is in the house
and is now going to be facing a very different
world than you were born into.
Oh absolutely and she explains what SIRI is
all the time to me but I just like to continue
with what Wendell indicated is that alarmed.
No.
but it does stress the need to have more conversations
like we're having today. Not with engineers
talking to engineers and attorneys only talking
to other attorneys but instead to talk across
fields. To ensure that we're speaking the
same language because we cannot figure out
these issues in our own individual cylinders
of excellence otherwise known as stovepipes.
Instead we have to talk across fields and
be able to address these issues anticipate
what the future problems are going to be.
And if we do that and we start talking it
using similar definitions and and start talking
the same language autonomous systems I think
are going to mirror what Gary talks about.
The more positive aspects, regardless of what
field we're talking about and much less the
negative ones.
Connecting the stovepipes and very definitely
important, law.
We shouldn't be afraid of seeing new kinds
of languages and all kinds of fields because
they have to talk to each other so that we
don't have other problems that we've had because
the stovepipes weren't connected before.
Absolutely. I mean you have to teach attorneys
a few things about control systems and feedback
loops though.
But he doesn't have to learn code does he.
No but then again they have to be able to
have a conversation with an engineer and not
have the eyes glaze over.
Well when lawyers get to talking law they're
talking their own code after all.
That's right. We have to stop using Latin.
I like latin. Some of it. Some of it. Well
listen tomorrow at 1:30 at NYU there's going
to be a salon on some aspects of this. Paging
Dr. robot how AI is revolutionizing health
care. You can find that on line I think exactly
how to buy a ticket for that at 1:30 tomorrow
at NYU. How AI is revolution revolutionizing
health care. Otherwise we're done. Our participants
will be in the lobby. Let's give them a round
of applause.